faire des efforts nécessaires mais ce
soit suffisamment l'état monsieur jean
pierre door oui merci monsieur le
président en question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur le ministre le monde agricole
est en deuil dans une commune rurale de
ma circonscription
un drame a secoué les agriculteurs et
toute la population locale un
agriculteur s'est donné la mort et il
s'ajoute aux 650 en france qui ont pris
cette ultime décision l'ayant accompagné
avec les élus locaux à sa dernière
demeure la colère et le désespoir
régnait dans ce village du gâtinais ce
qui était douloureux particulièrement le
cumul des nouveaux emprunts du au
respect de nouvelles normes européennes
qui entraîne des investissements
importants et la baisse du prix du lait
de 35% à provoquer pour eux des
résultats économiques catastrophiques
ils se retrouvent prisonniers de leurs
exploitations avec des charges de
travail importantes et un salaire de
misère pour ceux qui en ont encore un il
faut savoir que les solutions proposées
face à leur détresse entraîne des
charges supplémentaires et la spirale de
la descente aux enfers continue ma
question est la suivante est ce
acceptable sur le ministre de proposer
mille euros à chaque laitiers ou n'est
ce pas simplement une aumône la
politique agricole à venir doit tenir
compte sur toutes les charges
spécifiquement française avec une
augmentation du prix des productions qui
seraient payés aux agriculteurs
je vous remercie de votre réponse
merida plan l'état monsieur jean marie
le guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement merci
monsieur le président je veux
le député jean-pierre door je veux tout
d'abord excusé stéphane le foll qui est
en audition devant le conseil économique
social et environnemental est aussi
m'associer au nom du gouvernement à la
douleur de la famille vous rapportez
évidemment le cas tout à fait dramatique
et vous avez raison de souligner qu'
au-delà de cette
histoire personnelle et dramatique qu'il
y a dans les milieux des agriculteurs
des problèmes de suicides qui se posent
à tel point d'ailleurs que vous le savez
la msa a engagé un certain nombre de
process pour être au contact de ceux qui
sont en souffrance et essayer de les
aider et vous rattachez cela s'est
parfaitement légitime évidemment aux
difficultés que rencontrent
l'agriculture française et vous savez
que ces derniers mois nous avons été
l'agriculture française a été
particulièrement
sollicités par de nombreuses crises des
crises de marché comme celle du lait ou
de la viande des crises des filières
industrielles des crises sanitaires des
crises aussi lié aux changements aux
intempéries qui ont nombreuses dans tout
les domaines de l'agriculture plus
particulièrement vous insistez et c'est
tout à fait légitime sur la filière de
l'élevage c'est une crise sur lesquels
vous le savez le gouvernement est
intervenu il ya maintenant de très
nombreux mois d'une façon très
volontaire aussi bien à bruxelles qu'à
paris c'est pourquoi nous avons mis en
place des allègements de charges duprat
bhl plus de 600 millions d'euros ont été
versées aujourd'hui par l'état en
faisant en sorte qu'il y ait une baisse
de 7 points des charges aujourd'hui sur
les cotisations personnelles donc en ce
domaine comme dans d'autres il y avait
eu aussi à bruxelles une mobilisation
qui a fait que petit à petit le cours du
lait remonte et nous laisse entrevoir
une sortie par le haut de cette crise